plunges 299 as range of fears hit big
investors here's the front page of the
Philadelphia Inquirer with a picture of
some of the investors on the on the
floor of the stock market yesterday a
grimacing man on the front page of the
Washington Times and of course a front
page piece in The Wall Street Journal as
you would expect stock market plunges as
negative sentiment spreads to blue chips
and finally the one we showed earlier
this morning USA Today doubt plummets
299 points with this picture of this
woman who is in about every paper this
morning an Associated Press photo Paul
Krugman is joining with he's with us
this morning he is an MIT economist and
he has a new book out good morning
professor
good morning when you looked at these
headlines this morning what do you think
I have very mixed feelings on the one
hand I feel a little bit of
i-told-you-so because I'm one of these
people who's been skeptical about the
Dow on the other hand I have money I
mean the mystery was was not in the
mysteries not why the Dow fell yesterday
although we'd like to be able to predict
things like that it's it's been really
hard to explain why it was so high in
the first place and so there's a little
bit of vindication for those of us who
just couldn't understand how the numbers
made sense when when you look at these
and we know that one of the things that
you do is try to make this all held
makes sense to the average American out
there what part of it is most important
to them whether they're an investor or
not oh well if you're an investor
obviously you suddenly had a big paper
loss but if you're if you're a that gets
the worry that the thing the only thing
to be scared of most of this stock
market doesn't have a lot of bearing on
people don't have owned stocks you know
that like people say the stock market
has predicted six of the last three
recessions or something like that it's
not very it doesn't have a lot of impact
but if it's a really big fall then it
could spiral somewhat out of control we
could have a recession I guess I don't
believe that but that's certainly
everyone thinks 1929
I don't think 1929 is very likely but
that's what we all worry about this is
your book The Accidental theorist what
are you trying to do in it mostly I'm
trying to convince people that you can
you can do you can understand economics
that you can talk about
talk about it in plain English while at
the same time not sort of doing
something that's that's that's silly
that you can you can transmit it's sort
of a work of what can I say I'm somebody
who normally speaks incomprehensible
economies that's what I do
well John Maynard Keynes once said
economics though nobody will believe it
is a difficult and technical subject
sometimes it helps I find that some
funny funny graphs and maybe even a few
Greek letters is sometimes helpful for
thinking through a problem but once
you've done that it's often possible to
translate that back into plain English
and most people don't do that what I try
to do writing for fortune magazine
writing for slate and and in this book
is to try and do that for so that
ordinary intelligent citizens can can
understand some of what what the
arguments are really about what's the
hardest part of economics to explain I
think the hardest things are explaining
that in the economy a lot these sort of
double back and hid themselves from the
rear so that you know the total amount
of money that's spent in the economy is
equal to the total amount is earned
that's got to be true and yet trying to
keep that straight in your mind trying
to realize that you know all the money
has to go somewhere it has to end up
somewhere is is the kind of thing that
people get very wrong and particularly
when you're trying to understand
something like a recession that kind of
issue is really critical you write on
your web page actually which we have and
we can take a look at at some point in
time that your belief is that if an
op-ed piece or a column does not greatly
upset a substantial number of people
then the author is wasted as space so
I'm going to ask you then if this this
quote from your book was provocative or
you were just trying to get people upset
there is a good case to be made you
write that America's giant Icarus II has
gone too far and that we are too
generous to our retirees well look at
where the federal budget goes at this
point
aside from aside from spending from from
servicing the interest on the existing
national debt basically more than half
of what's left goes on retirees I'm
basically programs for the elderly if
you think about the welfare state we
actually give almost nothing to to
welfare queens with with their children
you know that that's a that's a that's
a myth that people like to talk about
and we give huge amounts to middle-class
retirees both in the form of medical
care in the form of Social Security
benefits it's if you ask where is why
has government grown why is the you know
why does despite all of these years of
our republicanism far as the government
bigger than it used to be is because the
retirees and that's a problem we are
going to take some phone calls you can
call us on the three lines you see at
the bottom of your screen we have one
for liberals one for conservatives and
one for moderates now does that
translate politically to economically
well is there an economic liberal and
economic conservative and an economic
that's my question yeah there's a
political one it's kind of a it's a
vague thing I mean it's it there are
economists for liberals I think of
myself as one we tend to have a hard
time dealing with with liberals who
aren't economists because there's a lot
of things they want to believe that that
that an economist who's who's who's a
liberal doesn't you know well give you
an example like I live in Cambridge
Massachusetts house prices are going up
because a lot of people are trying to
move in there some people there said
this is a terrible thing
all of these rich doctors and lawyers
are moving in and we should try to
discourage that by having a tax on
purchases of houses over I forget what
the number was but over some large sum
and people said but wait won't that be
hurting the homeowners the people who
already live in Cambridge and the answer
was oh that's okay
we'll make that will make the buyers pay
the tax not the sellers and apparently a
lot of liberals and cambers believed
that and the economists sit there and
say you know it doesn't matter who pays
the tax is gonna be reflected in the
home price anyway and and that's the
kind of thing that thing that happens
all the time so economists can be good
liberals I think but they don't
necessarily make comfortable liberals
beside yourself who are some other main
liberal economist oh well Alan Blinder
was number two at the Fed for a while
and he's now back at Princeton
University Janet Yellen the chair of the
Council of Economic Advisers although he
now has to hide it well because of his
his role Larry Summers the deputy
Treasury secretary I would regard as a
liberal and conservative conservative
economists oh well obviously Milton
Friedman the the grand old man in
conservative economics Robert barro got
some press when he got a very large job
offer that he didn't take at Columbia
Martin Feldstein at Harvard you know
there are the funny thing is I think
across that whole range there's amazing
amount of agreement despite the politics
it's much less politicized profession
than people imagine Paul Krugman is an
MIT economist he has the author of this
new book The Accidental theorist and
other dispatches from the dismal science
it's a book published by Norton first
call for him
Philadelphia good morning hi yeah I've
got two questions and then I'd like to
make our following statement my first
question is this given the claims by the
Republicans over the last few years that
it's then not Clinton who's caused
budget surplus therefore what do they
have any truth in their claim now which
started here USA this because of Clinton
the economy is falling or do those
problems have to fall under and solves
one - could you please address using
England as an example the effects of a
value-added tax or a sales tax which was
put it with and its effects on the
British economy in 1979 1980 and third
I'd like to address what I think is one
of the most fallacious statements I hear
Bill Clinton is allergic to tobacco in
England when people smoke marijuana they
put it in cigarettes
Bill Clinton can't inhale tobacco so
that bought for all the people who are
listening to c-span who are
conservatives or moderates who claims
Bill Clinton like he didn't inhale Bill
Clinton couldn't
inhale because he's allergic to tobacco
could you'd like questions all right
okay the truth is nobody no no no policy
is responsible for this budget surplus
no well you know we had a tax increase
right at the beginning of Clinton's
presidency which was fairly small which
Republicans said would have catastrophic
effects on the economy and in fact the
economy did just fine but they extra tax
revenue from that tax increase there's a
small part of what went right what's
gone rise the economy has just expanded
beyond anyone's expectations
and the reason for that is basically I
think that we've got lucky
you know they we don't necessarily know
very well how well the economy is going
to do what happened in this case was
that we used to experienced inflation
whenever unemployment got below around
6% now unemployment is down at four and
a half percent and inflation is still
subdued no one's quite sure why that
happened more mature labor force god
knows but certainly need that the
Republicans nor the Democrats did this
that was just a a piece of good luck and
that that stronger economy translates
into lower government expenditures on
things like unemployment insurance and
lots more tax revenue that's why the
budget is all of a sudden in surplus
it's kind of for the Republicans to say
oh well Clinton Clinton has caused the
slowdown last quarter and that's
ridiculous they think about what those
same people were saying five years ago
they were claiming that Clinton's
policies would throw the economy into a
terrible recession which they were
already in advance contrasting with the
prosperity of the Reagan years and the
Reagan years show how Republican
policies succeed and now we've had a
expansion that's even bigger than what
we had in the 1980s and they're there
that has nothing to do with Clinton's
policies but one quarter of slow growth
is all because of Bill Clinton
the truth is it's it's nobody is in
charge of this it's just the private
sector doing its thing Miami Florida on
the moderate line good morning good
morning nice to be on the c-span welcome
I'm very concerned about the five
trillion dollar debt that we have in
this country and all of a sudden we have
a little surplus and all they want to do
is just give it back to the people and
reduce the taxes instead of paying off
the debt if they give that money back
won't that then cause inflation because
they'll be more money in the in the
marketplace and more people buying more
things it'll make things go up in
addition to that I think one of the
things that is terrible is that
everybody all these politicians in
Washington
who are puppets of the
military-industrial complex are
screaming about the missiles in China
and in Iran and Iraq in Korea they want
to spend a trillion dollars of tax money
to build an impossible thing star wars
situation when we have Trident
submarines we spend over a billion
dollars on Trident submarines so that if
anybody ever attacked any insane person
ever attacked the United States with one
submarine could wipe out a country okay
thanks bye I mean let's try to stick
with the economic issues let me tell you
the truth about our budget surpluses
it's great news that we've got those
four pluses but the way the US
government budget works there's two
parts there's the trust fund Social
Security and Medicare which are supposed
to you know be self-financing over the
long-term and then there's the rest of
the budget the rest of the budget is not
in a big surplus all of the surplus that
we we have basically all that I think
ninety eight percent of the surplus
we're expecting over the next decade or
so is in those trust funds they're
they're accumulating money they have to
accumulate that money to pay the future
benefits of the recipients so there
isn't any money to give away if Congress
decides that it should give away tax
cuts it's basically rating it you know
it's raiding the larder for future
Social Security and Medicare recipients
and it's an amazing piece of slate of
hand that anyone thinks that there's
actually money to hand out and in this
budget which is you know it is not
really in surplus if we took the long
view Cleveland Texas you're next good
morning on the conservative good morning
I'm glad to get through the c-span I
love it welcome I wanted to tell him he
did
pardon me he did not use the word
means-testing while ago for the elders
that were too good to our elders but I
take great exception to that my husband
and I always pay cash for everything we
bought not that we ever made a fabulous
salary we didn't we just didn't buy
anything if we could not afford it
we paid heavy taxes when my husband
retired
we paid and then when I my husband died
and this last year was the first year I
had to file without the two dependents
and boy did they ever stick it to me
again
and I resent bitterly him saying that
because I saved my money that I need
means-testing now and I did let's be a
blossom I thought that's okay collar
thanks very much I think we got your
point mr. Krugman I think of it this way
it's someone who is now retired is for
sure receiving far more in benefits than
the amount that that he or she paid in
during during that their lifetime up to
this point you are in fact receiving a
large net benefit large net aid from the
government you may feel that morally you
deserve it and and I'm not going to
quarrel with that but the fact is that
you are receiving that large net benefit
that people who are paying for that are
young working people now who are paying
hefty very hefty Social Security taxes
much much heavier than you did when you
were young and who cannot look forward
to an equivalent sort of transfer the
next generation because the next
generation is not going to be as big as
as the current generation so I mean if
you actually just look at the flows of
money young working people are paying a
lot of money to older people they cannot
expect comparable benefits when they get
when they get older so in something has
got to give here either we have to to
find some way of ramping down the rate
of growth of those benefits or we have
to find some way of taxing other people
in society and you know it's it's just
arithmetic it's it's not really morality
it's just a question of adding up Paul
Kruger Krugman rather has been with MIT
since 1979 with some interruptions yeah
with some and before that what oh well
Toni Yale for a couple years and before
as a student and he also is you've got
your PhD though at MIT that's right
when is that when 77 originally from
Albany New York and he also writes for
slate and Fortune magazine Los Angeles
California good morning good morning
thank you for this opportunity Watson
professor I'd like to ask you what
economic impact would you foresee from
the Congress passing the tobacco tax and
in any of your calculations do you
factor in anything such as social good
gosh I actually don't know I pass on the
tobacco tax I just haven't done my
homework I was just telling our host
that I'm like that old comedian
professor Irwin Corey who was the
world's greatest expert who had an
opinion on everything but I don't have
an opinion on that one
I think if you're serious about
economics a social good is what you're
after
you can't put a number on that so what
you're trying to do is make your best
guess about what your objectives are and
then you're trying to figure out the the
best way to get that you know people
have this idea that economists know the
you know the price of everything in the
value of nothing there are economists
like that but there are people like that
all through society I don't I don't
think that we're any worse than anybody
else and I'd be perfectly happy to
sacrifice a couple of points of GDP for
environmental improvement for a
healthier society if I knew how to do it
what's a GDP sorry gross domestic
product and what's that that's the value
of everything produced in the society or
actually you know it's it's the sum of
the the value of all the production and
that's you hear that on the news all the
time it's and why does it matter
oh you know it's kind of a loose measure
of how much we're doing when the GDP
goes down unemployment goes up that's
the most important thing like the GDP
yeah the GDP has to grow around two and
a half percent a year for the young to
sort of produce enough jobs to keep to
keep to keep the unemployment rate from
rising beyond that well you know GDP per
capita now is about seven times what it
was at the turn of the century that
translates into the fact that most
people don't live in tenements anymore
it's not a measure of human happiness
but it's a it's a kind of a crude index
of material well-being Boston you're
next on the moderate line good morning
hello Boston good morning good morning
I had like two questions one was when he
was talking about the budget is he
saying that the unified budget entails
the trust funds and that trust fund
wasn't it agreed that they wouldn't
touch the trust fund the other question
is now my father walked the pavement he
was a laborer then he went to work and
he paid into Social Security now when he
was working he was getting very little
paid but they took out Social Security
he never abused medical it was only in
the hospital four times in his life my
mother's only been in the hospital three
times in her life other than having
babies so I don't think many of the
senior citizens or abusing Medicare some
people might be getting Medicare that
don't need it like mr. Reagan who has a
pension from the state from the actus
and from the government I don't deny him
that he needs care or his wife but
people like that shouldn't be getting
that much in social good that's great
thank you the unified budget does
include Social Security and when people
say we're not going to touch those
security here's the way to think about
it it's like a family which says that
well we've got this special savings
account and whatever we do we're not
going to stop putting money at that
savings account because we need that for
the kids education so we're always going
to put money into that account but you
know we really want to buy some of those
things that we just saw it at in the
store so we're gonna we're going to run
up our credit card bills and that's okay
because we're not touching those savings
were putting aside it's not the truth is
it's a wash the truth is that that you
are in fact reading those savings but
you're just keeping them in on different
pages of your ledge
and that's basically been what the US
government has been doing up until just
this year it has been raiding Social
Security although it doesn't say so now
thank heavens we've gotten to a point
where we are not actively raiding Social
Security but we're not building up any
reserve that we can use to say but
either you brought a story with you this
morning from the front of the USA Today
oh gosh yes I know I just noticed that
there's a story on the USA Today about
about actually what what what we call
trailing spouses the about husband's
relocating to follow their wives and is
that to the economy but when it's when
traditionally had it been the other way
around almost we're getting pretty close
to an equal you know to a half female
workforce and it's too slowly but still
gradually women are moving up the scale
in terms of of the responsibility the
special skills that they have in their
jobs there's no reason why husbands
shouldn't be as willing to follow why as
as vice versa and for once I have the
moral high ground I'm a trailing spouse
I I said there was an interruption in my
years at MIT I moved out to to
California for three years and then back
and it was entirely because of my wife's
job and what did she do she's also a
professor and the daughter of economics
sorry
it's dinner dinner conversations can be
pretty dull you're next on the
conservative line what I want to say is
you know back years ago when my husband
and I were working you raise their
children pay their taxes and we saved
their money we didn't go out and defend
it to spend it but I when we put our
money away and we drew interest on our
money we had to pay tax on that now that
I'm Lou every time my husband's dead I'm
retired and when I get my money back
from my investments I pay tax on that
and I don't think that's right that I
should have to pay tax and tax and tax
because back years ago you couldn't put
money aside unless you really sacrifice
so I say to these younger people if they
sacrifice a little bit they'd have
something when they grow up when they
wouldn't get older but they don't want
to sacrifice anything they need to new
boats as two or three cars a big home
which they I can't believe they buy a
or better or five-bedroom home and they
don't even have any children this is
ridiculous
that's right thank ya for what is I mean
you can find this is a very big
country's one of the things actually
said in my book The Accidental theorist
is that this is such a big country that
you can find not just one example but
lots of examples of anything and there
are young people who are spendthrifts
and there are older people who really
are are are scraping by and there's not
just you know one or two but there's
millions in both categories still if you
look at this country in the broad view
back up from it what you see is a lot of
very affluent older people the most
affluent elderly generation that that's
ever existed in human history when I
think about boats and and big houses I
actually if you check the the median age
of people who owned who owned boats I
think you'd find it's amazingly high and
a lot of young people who are having a
very hard time making those first steps
up the ladder partly because people now
pay a much higher proportion of their
wages into Social Security and Medicare
trust funds then then their their
parents did at the same age and Buren
Arkansas your next good morning good
morning it seems to me like capitalism
should tax capital instead of labor by
taxing assets instead of income and it
all would work out right okay the
problem is unfortunately we do what I
was saying before about about liberals
and economists you know having liberal
economists sometimes having find
themselves in awkward positions we do
live under a capitalist system it's like
Winston Churchill said about democracy
it's the worst system known except all
the others that have been tried now and
then and you can't have that system
unless there are enough incentives for
people to accumulate capital unless you
you leave people with the incentive to
invest the incentive to take risks and
so on
that doesn't mean no taxes on capital
that doesn't mean that all of the tax
burden must must fall on on the poorest
and the population but it does mean that
you can't finance the kind of social
safety net that I believe we need unless
you're prepared to tax a lot more than
just just wealth than just assets
this email and from mr. William woods
asked you a question professor Krugman
says that the money always has to go
somewhere when there is a big sell-off
like yesterday where does the money go
and how much of it leaves the country
that's a favorite
that's a classroom exercise it is a
selling wave on the on you ask people of
what what's happening when there's a
selling wave on on Wall Street and the
answer of course is selling wave is also
a buying wave all of the money every
everyone bought one of those stocks that
that was sold right there was always
somebody on the other side what actually
happened was that there was a lot of
transactions but the price fell none of
the money went out of the country no not
not yesterday not on not in one of those
dramatic events something that people
probably don't realize is that on
balance you take take the whole sum of
things capital is actually coming into
the u.s. not out of it that is if you
add up all of the flows of money of
people buying bonds and stocks in the US
there's more bonds and stocks being
bought in the US than US companies and
so on are investing overseas the the
opposite side of that is is that we run
a trade deficit because overall all the
money has to balance out so we actually
export less stuff less cars and
airplanes than we buy but on the other
hand we sell more bonds and stocks than
we buy abroad most people imagine the
opposite is true most people imagine
that the money must be flowing overseas
and vast quantities but the u.s. is one
of the world's biggest net recipients of
foreign money you know it's it's not the
way people imagined Mount Pleasant
Michigan on the moderate line good
morning yeah I was wondering it like had
the professor comment on what he thought
of mr. Forbes plan on privatizing Social
Security and if it be true that if we
invested in mutual funds that we would
get more percentage back than what we
did what the system and also I'd like
with the comment on
mr. Forbes had a plan of I believe it
would like people under $36,000 a year
wouldn't pay taxes I like that here the
opinion on that point okay
uh the second one is basically his
numbers don't add up that that you asked
about those plans and they always depend
upon some unspecified saving in
government expenditure that balances the
books and and you ask well where is this
cut gonna come and then they are
carefully not specific because again you
ask where does most of the government's
money go and the answer is retirees the
I had for a long time been sort of
unwilling to get too much into Social
Security because it's a real technical
issue and but lately it's the discussion
they're sort of set my what what my
double-talk detector is vibrating and I
started to to to work on a little more
and talk with people who really do know
a lot about it and let me tell you I I'm
starting to believe that the whole
Social Security debate including the
Forbes plan especially is is way
wandering way off into Fantasyland on
the one hand people say well we can
invest the money in stocks because
stocks will earn a higher return and
then people say well isn't the stock
market looking kind of overvalued aren't
won't we just just at the point when we
start to invest lots of money in the
stock market the stock market will start
to look to lose some of that money and
people say oh well don't worry because
the stock market's values do make sense
because people don't demand the extra
return on stocks that they used to it's
the jargon phrases the equity premium so
you want to make sense of the current
value of the stock market you have to
say that the old equity premium is gone
but then you say well why do you think
that's investing in stocks will give you
a higher return and therefore you know
what will will be better than the
current system the answer is oh well
stocks have always earned more than
bonds look at the equity premium you
can't believe both of those things at
the same time there's there's a
contradiction and yet the same people
like Forbes say both things so this is
we are really in a situation where
people have got this idea that putting
putting our funds into the stock market
is going to make all of the problems
with Social Security go away
it's not entirely a bad idea but the
idea that it's it's a magic solution
that you just wave your hand across it
and it goes away is is really silly and
and I'm finding it a little bit scary as
well well this person who emailed in
earlier today Laurel Murphy from
Lutherville Maryland had a question for
you saying that you she or she was too
nervous to to phone in but here's the
question it's a little involved there is
so much political rhetoric about Social
Security and so few people understand
how the process really works and what
happens when there is a surplus in
Social Security taxes over Social
Security payments the law requires this
surplus to be invested only in Treasury
securities which are only promises to
pay from future tax revenues could you
please explain and plane a non political
language why the surplus is not really
invested if the money is not spent
somehow
if it were not spent by the government
as it comes in wouldn't there be a
terrible drain on the money supply which
would affect our monetary policy wow
that is an involved question it is let
me give you the the short that let me
answer the last part first you can see
if I can reconstruct the rest of it
luckily we have another way of injecting
money into the economy what happens is
that alan greenspan instructs the what
basically goes out there prints dollars
uses them to buy up US government debt
and that just put those puts those
dollars into circulation so the United
States is a happy country we are
financially sound enough so that our
money supply is not really connected to
our budget there are unhappy countries
like Russia that really have to print
money to pay their bills and then then
it really is directly connected but we
are we have plenty of wiggle room on
that so I I don't really worry about the
monetary consequences there is a that
the call has a good point though that
basically Social Security is backed only
by the only by the the future taxing
ability of the US government and that's
why you really should not think of it as
being something that stands outside the
we the US government needs to run
surpluses to pay for the eventual
payments to our aging population that
the bottom line and there's no other way
to know what no way around that
Paul Krugman is an MIT economist and he
has the author of this new book The
Accidental theorist and other dispatches
from the dismal science next to
Jacksonville Florida our conservative
line good morning good morning you're on
the air sir go ahead yes professor
Krugman I think that you're one of the
people that's adding to the confusion
about on Social Security I'm a CPA
Jacksonville and I it always appears to
be that CPAs deal with real money an
economists deal with theoretical money
and you just did it again there is no
social security trust fund the money
goes out as soon as it comes in so what
you just said we have to keep
accumulating these surpluses we don't
there is no accumulated surplus it's
only a paper entry in the books of the
American government I think that's I
think that's what I was saying but let
me let me put it a different way
the US government ideally should be
paying down its debt in order to prepare
for the days when it actually has to
start paying a lot of money to Social
Security recipients when the US
government pays dad's debt you know pays
off some of the the money at now owes
that money goes somewhere it comes back
to my earlier point about money always
has to go somewhere
basically the people who are now holding
US government bonds are going to want to
hold some other form of wealth and what
we hope is that they will then go and
invest it in some real asset and in so
doing increase the ability of our
economy to produce that's what people
you know again if you if you really
follow it through that's what people are
saying you say that we need to run
surpluses to pay for our future Social
Security benefits and you know I mean
you're right that you do need to keep
track of these things and you have to
that the ultimate bottom line is is
factories and shopping malls and and and
and investments in new technology
luckily we don't have to figure out
exactly which investments should be made
all we have to do is provide people with
the incentive to make them Chantilly
Virginia on the liberal line good
morning hello I'm mr. Krugman I read
your books on the age at the minute
expectations and in there you mention
the concept of a natural rate of
unemployment the Nehru
and there's that space that we must have
an unemployment rate of about six
percent somewhere around there they were
to avoid inflation and therefore invent
if I don't put my rate gets below that
the Fed will tighten the money supply to
UM to long keep unemployment rate up now
in that light could you say then that
poor people are destined to be poor
based on this economic theory and in the
situation in this country where race
plays such a big part then our black
people destined to be poor much more
than white I like your pain on that
thank you
your your basically let's put this way
the the we do have a problem the natural
rate of unemployment or the neighbor or
this this this limit on how on how hot
you can run the economy unfortunately is
not something that is a moral judgment
it's not a political judgment it's a
it's either true or it's not and I
believe that it is true although I also
believe that that that natural rate has
fallen for a variety of reasons and and
so six percent is not the right number
now although probably four point five is
too low the problem is you can't you
know it's not it's not a trade off
that's available you can't say well
let's just accept the inflation because
they the what what we what we've
experienced in the past is you try to
keep unemployment low for extended
period of time the inflation just goes
faster and faster and eventually becomes
intolerable the worst hit by
unemployment are minority groups are the
working poor that's why you certainly
don't want the economy to run with any
higher unemployment that it needs and
you know I'm a great fan of Alan
Greenspan because he's had the courage
to to do nothing
he said the courage to give the economy
a loose rein and let it expand until he
actually sees the inflation and that's
done more probably for for the the poor
than any social policy in the last
twenty years the one thing that you can
say though is that that that's not the
only tool we have we can do other things
particularly to help the
I'm poor and the other thing I'm a fan
of besides Alan Greenspan is programs
like the Earned Income Tax Credit which
are actually things that top up the
income of the working poor make it
possible for someone to have a
minimum-wage job and yet be above the
poverty line and in so doing also
provide a great incentive for people to
take those first steps of the ladder
into the labor market if when I say I'm
a liberal it's because I think we should
be doing that sort of thing on a much
bigger scale than we now do that's that
kind of social policy icing is the only
answer you can't do it just with with
inflation Congressman John Boehner on
our program tomorrow Florence Alabama
you're next with professor Krugman good
morning hello yes I like to say they
agree with you about great things you
had a great job also I have a kind of a
different question with all the boomers
that are beginning to exit the job
market what kind of strain these you see
there especially there's gonna be
dissing into savings you know a workers
coming in the job market can deserve a
premium are there enough workers coming
in how do you see that you know coming
out Oh
the boomers don't actually start as need
a job market just yet although I I'm
starting to feel like I could use
retirement right now but the I mean the
main thing is that we're gonna have a
population that's going to have a lot
smaller proportion of people who are
actually in their working years and
that's where all of these problems with
Social Security and Medicare come from
they come from the the fact that they're
the the number of recipients relative to
the numbers of payers into the system is
going to decline a lot now we'd like to
hope I'd like to imagine that young
people will get a special premium that
there'll be high wages for new job
entrance so far you don't see that
except in a few scattered places I mean
what what 27 year olds are making in
Silicon Valley or on Wall Street is
pretty amazing but unfortunately that's
not typical of the country as a whole
we don't quite know why earlier caller
said that he had ridden one of your
previous books how many of you written
Oh
you know I don't actually I'm not sure
it says 16 on my homepage but I think
there's 17 so he lost one somewhere yeah
it's well you know one of the things
when you browned you start to you have
edited volumes and and so on but there
are there are four books that I think
are comprehend are in English or in
English yes wait which are those age of
diminished expectations was the caller
mentioned peddling prosperity pop
internationalism and the accidental
theorist which is the highest selling so
far well the first of those agent
diminished expectations has been adopted
for use as a secondary textbook a lot so
that's not fair
but that one is the highest selling so
far do you use it in your own classes
actually I don't
I feel inhibited it's sort of like your
curve I don't want econ one to be
Krugman 101 I just can't bring myself to
do that how many people do you teach an
econ one 350 at one time it's actually
1402 is what's called about my tea but
yes that one alas I've got the big
freshman introductory course how do you
keep them interested in the topic like
economics ah by talking about the world
and about what's happening now I'm gonna
I'm doing do with this fall and the
economic crisis in Asia is perfect I
mean it's terrible thing to say but for
keeping students interested every every
time we talk about things that can go
wrong in the economy I can say let's
talk about what happened in Indonesia
last week and give you a concrete
example of exactly that kind of thing
happening why our services are saying
this morning the dollar sank to its
lowest level against the yen in about a
week today following what happened in
New York stocks yesterday and that the
Asian markets followed any surprises to
that a little surprised that the Asian
markets went down with that I mean I
mean that the this trend has been that
the dollar is getting very strong
against the yen which is not really
about what's right with us it's about
what's wrong with them
Japan is the wonder of the world now in
the its if you ask me what scares what
scares me most about today's world
economy it is Japan not so much because
things are so terrible
but because it's not supposed to happen
to a country like that there are a rich
sophisticated advanced country with a
solid legitimate government no far in
debt and they're just sliding down and
it's in there looking like a 30s economy
and it's like seeing the Black Death
return I didn't think that could happen
today it does it beg the question if it
could have happened there could it
happen here it exactly makes you wonder
that if you ask me I would say you're at
first I think Europe looks more like
Japan than we do but still it could
happen it could happen elsewhere unless
we figure out how to solve that Atlanta
you're next on a conservative line good
morning good morning professor how are
you I have a point to make it and I had
like a question answered from me first
of all I lost about six thousand dollars
in paper yesterday or in the market
myself and I'm really not worried at all
most the people I've talked to or this
is a simple correction and it's the only
game in town so we really don't have a
choice in the matter
the other question I like to ask you
don't hang up when I say so you can
answer the question is I'd like you to
on how much actual taxes are paid by by
people in this country is it the fact
that the top 2 percent of wage earners
pay a little more than 20 percent of the
overall tax base and the top 25 percent
earners in this country pay almost 80
percent of the taxes and the bottom 25%
pay the west and as far as earners pay
less than 2 percent of the overall tax
situation in this country that that's
not true could you correct me please ok
I don't have those numbers exactly in
hand I think the thing to remember is
that as that income is is very highly
concentrated you know that the that the
top 20% of families have got nearly half
of the total income in this country and
that the top 5% of families have got at
more than a fifth of the income in this
country nothing that is necessarily such
a terrible thing but when you hear those
numbers about about concentration of tax
payments you have to remember that the
taxes are only slightly more
concentrated and then the income it's
it's not we have a system that overall
is progressive that is the tax rate
rises as you make more money but only a
little bit and if if a relatively small
number of people
an awful lot of our taxes is because a
relatively small number of people earn
an awful lot of income in this country
it's not it's not because we have we we
especially single them out for
punishment
is there a geographical area where the
highest income people live Connecticut I
believe why is that because that's where
high paid employees of New York
companies live yeah and also of course
Silicon Valley and if you go to places
like that pittsfield massachusetts in
the liberal line good morning you know I
was wondering I was going to ask the
question about the top percent a and a
hundred percent but also there hasn't
been across the living adjustment is
pharisee base amount sixty five thousand
since nineteen eighty eighty two I think
it was and how can you pay a cost of
living on the bottom so the people
drawing Social Security in without
putting on the max put no social cost of
living out of the top you got to adjust
those two things if you adjust them
you'll probably have a lot of money but
you don't try to do it the simple way
you've got to take a penny away from a
poor guy year nickel away from another
guy live in poverty and but the real
simple things like adjusting the amount
of money early it was sixty five
thousand in nineteen eighty two it's
still sixty five thousand limit you're
gonna pay it Social Security professor
if you were just bad thank you very much
actually I don't
I should probably pass on that III don't
think the facts are right but I should
pass on it cuz I don't have to totally
clear myself what is he mentioned
poverty how do you define poverty in the
economic turn it don't mean poverty is a
basically poverty was was originally
just a guideline for for social spending
it's it's a subjective thing you sort of
back in in the 50s we decided a
government bureaucrats decided what they
thought was the the necessary
things that a family had to have to be
have a decent way of life and and ever
since we've we've calculated the poverty
line there's enough money to buy those
things the one thing that you should
know though when you see statistics
about poverty in the u.s. is we have not
changed the definition for a long long
time maybe the things that are in that
grouping that you add up yeah it's just
been adjusted basically for inflation so
some people say well you know if if
we're if we still have 12 percent of the
population in poverty that's because you
always think that 12% of the population
is poor that's not true what's actually
if you took that that poverty definition
it fell dramatically during the 50s and
60s and up through the early 70s and it
has not fallen a lot since then risen in
some years risen among children that's
not because we keep on changing the
definitions it's because we have a
growing economy where basically none of
that growth has gone to the poorest
people Richland Center Wisconsin on the
moderate line good morning hello you're
on the air sir go ahead professor how do
you relate the farming gross farm
economy into the general economy of the
United States
Wow there are not a lot of farmers left
that's basically because the farmers are
so efficient it takes very few farmers
to produce all the food we need and and
a lot for the rest of the world as well
farming is very different from the rest
of the economy and if you were to ask
where are some of the strains right now
US economy showing a lot of it is
showing up in the farm sector this very
strong dollar is pricing our food our
agricultural products out of world
markets that there's low inflation rate
that we have now is being one of the
things that's really keeping it down is
low food prices again because of a
glutton world markets for agricultural
products not a happy time to be a farmer
and to some extent this great prosperity
that the rest of us feel is is that the
farmers expense so is this is what
happens with the farmers somewhat
cyclical to the to the economy like
anything else there is somewhat
different because for one thing farming
is probably more dependent on exports
than any other part of the US economy
you know we really that's really where
where the
are growing wheat not for not for you or
me but for people around the world it's
very sensitive to things that seem
arcane to most people like the foreign
exchange rate of the dollar and so it's
not the same cycle the rest of us live
on but it's terribly cyclical Delmer is
it Del Mar California yes deal more good
morning on the conservative line hello
I'm a little bit illiterate when it
comes to this but I had a couple of
questions for you one is like we we
talked about the national deficit and so
far how we're in debt where does money
come from out of like these funds for
aid to other nations for one and for two
like the prior guest that was on the
show mentioned President Reagan when he
takes a flight somewhere say I believe
it was China they were talking about 40
million dollars for his security and all
that stuff where does that money come
from is that taxpayers money or can you
explain that point
yeah that's taxpayers money and foreign
aid is is also taxpayers money but have
some sense of the magnitudes okay this
is a very big country it's a very rich
country forty million dollars sounds
like a lot of money it means that every
the average American has paid one-sixth
of one cent towards that trip right it's
not it's not something you're going to
notice in your tax bill foreign aid is
an incredibly small number that's to say
it's a few billion dollars and the
famous line of senator senator Everett
Dirksen you know a billion here a
billion there and eventually you're
talking about real money but these days
that's a long time before that becomes a
big thing we spend trivial amounts on
foreign aid we spend I'm sure that we
spend more on Medicare in a week I hope
this is right but it's close to be right
we spend more on Medicare in a week than
we spend on on foreign aid in a whole
year so it's these are just not these
these things people get very emotional
about they see President Clinton flying
around in Air Force One and they say
that's my money they get very excited at
seeing that we've given they have the
idea that we're giving a lot of foreign
aid although you know
those people you asked exactly who are
we giving this foreign aid to can't give
you an answer these are not important
parts of the budget let me ask you about
the issue of the IMF we talked a little
bit about the International Monetary
Fund in our earlier segment is that a
good way to help out the Asian countries
it's the only way we have yeah I mean
what are we going to do we have our
strategy we're dealing with countries
that are in crisis you know the world
has has got a kind of a safety net that
is the only thing that we have which is
the IMF basically goes and then lends
money to countries that are in in
trouble and to give them some breathing
room to to work their way out it's the
same thing that happens if there's a run
on a bank in the United States for some
reason people get nervous about the bank
and you know when people have a run on a
bank that can bust the bank even if the
bank is fundamentally sound because it
can't come up with the cash right away
what hat will happen is that the Federal
Reserve Alan Greenspan basically will
lend the bank money so that it has the
cash to meet its depositors and has time
to convince people that it's okay the
IMF is sort of doing the equivalent of
that for the world it's what we call the
lender of last resort now it's a pretty
poor excuse for it it doesn't have
enough money it's kind of slow it
doesn't have the power that the IMF is -
sorry that the Federal Reserve has to
sort of march in there and and demand to
see all the books but in a very
dangerous world it's the best thing
we've got this is the book The
Accidental theorist it's his newest of
16 or 17 something like that I have to
figure this one Norwalk Connecticut on
the liberal line good morning I'd like
to make a comment about Social Security
and ask for a couple quick questions
right one the the earnings base has been
increased every year in line with the
CPI in answer to the previous caller
this increases every year so he's just
uninformed now my question has to do
with your comment that Social Security
is really being raided by the government
because the excess money is being used
to buy government
other of bonds and sounds security in
the world I don't see how you reach that
conclusion it that a month of raining no
I'm sorry what I said was that up until
basically up until this year when we
finally started to run a a small surplus
it was being rated not because social
security was being used to raise to buy
government bonds but because the US
government was selling a lot more bonds
than just the ones to social security
basically we were borrowing money from
it didn't really matter from where but
typically from Japanese pension funds
and insurance companies to pay for the
ongoing expenses of the government just
in the same way that well think of the
analogy I used it's like a family that
is carefully putting money aside in a
savings account to pay for the kids
education while simultaneously running
up a bill on their credit card
we're not the question is not whether
that savings account is solid it's a
solid as anything but by running up that
bill on the credit card they are in
effect raiding those savings and that's
that has been the situation right up
until just now and if the economy should
have to slump it'll be happening again
so faxes and emails for you professor
Krugman economists in the press have
ignored the fact that approximately 1.5
trillion tax-free dollars has been
pumped into the economy over the last
six to eight years from insurance
companies and disaster relief programs
all due to natural disasters tax free
money always Prime's the economy any I
don't really that that number sounds
awfully high to me that sounds like it's
counting every insurance payment that's
been made but I don't really have an
answer this email why has no one
mentioned that a value-added tax taxes
the lower wage earners at a much higher
rate than the rich that's not actually
true it's it's only true to the extent
that rich people save you know spend
less of their their income on
consumption but no value-added tax gets
rid of whatever progressivity we do have
in the current system and that's a
problem faster Krugman in 1961 President
Kennedy proposed a type of tax cut which
Republicans like to quote today what was
the essence of this tax cut with regards
to amounts in economic categories first
of all it was it was tiny compared with
the kinds of deficits that
in the 80s I mean it just wasn't wasn't
a big thing and secondly was it started
with an economy that lots of slack in it
lots of unemployed people that could be
put to work doesn't doesn't bear
comparison with today's you know it's
squeaking tight labor market and from
Bud Powell in Kerrville Texas mr.
Krugman you are a socialist are you not
that's a wonderful thing I have any
suggestion the government can do
anything and you're called a socialist
but read my current fortune column at
which I make fun of Marx Bowie Maryland
on the moderate line good morning
yes sir I'm have questions on the Social
Security system I sent for a report from
the Social Security system on how much I
contributed to the Social Security
system from 1961 to 1996 I contributed
$48,000 now that's a half-truth because
my employer contributed the same amount
mm-hmm now if you take 3% compounded
yearly in 1996 there should be quote
unquote in my account a hundred and
thirty three thousand six hundred
dollars okay if I put don't put another
dime in there at three percent by the
time I reach 62 I would have $190,000
now three percent is a very very
conservative interest rate would you not
agree and if so how can the Social
Security system be out of money based on
these figures and and have have you
figured out how much are likely to
collect over the course of your
retirement based on what the Social
Security system is says I'm entitled to
I'm entitled to $1400 a month okay now
on the 3% figure a retiring at 62
that $1400 a month would get me ten
years and eight months which would put
me at 72 but it's going to be drawing
interest on the unspent money following
and I would I would get past 72 up to 76
now the male life expectancy is less
than 76 so if I die my wife is going on
my is drawing on my account is gonna
draw a left then the $1400 the month do
you follow me let me just ask how old
are you sir
right now I'm 53 which means that you
are a Boomer and the the the basic rule
here or you're not quite a Boomer but
you'reyou're just on the cusp of it the
basic rule is that people born before
the baby boom get a lot more than they
put into the system people who are born
during the baby boom as it currently
stands will roughly breakeven which
sounds me to be about right given your
numbers and people who are now in their
late 20s or early 30s are the ones who
are really going to get socked under the
current system well they they do I mean
that's there's if there's ever a civil
war in this country it's gonna be
between the young and the old not not on
long some other lines because it is a
system that is really taxing them for
the taxing people younger than me to pay
benefits of people older than me car
would New Jersey and the conservative
line good morning good morning earlier
you were saying the Japanese situation
is very extreme and very dangerous
our government is advising them to have
tax cuts help them resolve this and I
think that sounds like trickle-down
economics why is it good for them and
their for us and secondly should the
Social Security surplus the invested any
differently than my company is pension
plan should they both be prudently
invested okay the second one the answer
is yes so we can or no I'm not sure if
they think Social Security should be
invested like a pension plan is the
answer the there's a headline somewhere
here about about Japan I think it's in
the near time
which is that they are in fact the the
new finance minister who is 78 years old
by the way things that they they should
have large tax cuts there is a
difference between Japan and the US
which is that the US has as far as we
can tell the you know we have the lowest
unemployment rate we've had for 25 years
and they have the highest unemployment
rate they've had for 40 years so they
have an economy where there's a lot of
basically unemployed people unemployed
resources that could be brought into use
when all is said and done I actually
don't believe these tax cuts are gonna
work I think that the Japanese are so
depressed about the state of their
economy that they will not spend those
tax cuts and it won't stimulate their
economy I think their God knows the
Japanese need advice but I don't think
they're getting very good advice from
the US what what should the person who's
just watching this issue as a layman
look for in either the US economy or the
Japanese economy to watch to be either
more fearful or get a feel that it's
playing out for the Japanese economy
which is that is my obsession lately the
thing you want to look for as a sign
that things are really getting worse
would be to see some public loss of
confidence in the bank's if we we
haven't heard about bank runs in Japan
despite the fact that we now think that
their banks have got a trillion dollars
of bad debt if you start to see bank
runs in Japan that's when when I think
would become appropriate to panic if
when it comes to the US economy I guess
there two things I've got two
contradictory worries one is if we start
to see some inflation finally the other
is if if what happened to the stock
market yesterday turns out to be the
start of a trend and then then we better
hope that Alan Greenspan is really very
is is as good as I think he is and and
starts starts cutting interest rates
fast this is the book The Accidental
theorists and other dispatches from the
dismal science our guest has been Ben
Paul Krugman who is an MIT professor the
book is published by Norton thank you
for joining us this morning